en direct du national agen 2016 deuxième
journée aujourd'hui je suis avec des
champions en france mais sur ses quatre
titres à son actif
sophie millet bonjour sophy alors belle
journée pourtant aujourd'hui oui ça
s'est plutôt bien passé
parce que j'ai fait une assez bonne
partie aujourd'hui sans trop de fautes
ou par ailleurs faute oui tout en
évoluant yart a fait une partie face à
nîmes au mayorat 10 août avait semblé
pris davantage à weave à gt gt gagnante
simplement
mais bon j'ai pris trop de temps dans
l'ouverture surtout brillé après après
c'est vrai que même si on crise de temps
j'ai pu placer deux petites mains de
tactique après j'ai eu un moment de
panique et malheureusement laissé
échapper la partie
oui alors quand tu as échapper des
parties nord et est de mauvaise humeur
on a remarqué ça va mais c'est toujours
un peu rageant quoi ces cds demi points
qui s'envolent dès la fin bon ben ça
peut faire la différence donc ouais
alors aux quatre titres à son actif ça
veut dire que tu n'as que fil entre
guillemets et que la cdc vrai que le
titre de champion c'est quand même pas
rien mais tu as deux titres de retard en
quelque sorte sur elle n'ira donc il ya
un peu un challenge entre vous là
parce que vous êtes vous êtes bien placé
pour détenir le record quoi en fait des
celmira quel record mais n'était pas si
loin de pouvoir éventuellement le
rattraper son record oui bon je pense
pas trop à ça ça j'ai eu un peu une
mauvaise passe dans mon jeu donc
donc là j'essaye juste de serrure
essayait bien jouer et puis et puis et
puis on verra bien à la fin ce que ce
que ça donne d'accord alors on va
regarder ta partie aujourd'hui face à
cyrielle mon père aussi une nouvelle
joueuse du national quand ils sont
premiers elle a gagné sa qualification b
l'an dernier en faisant un bon résultat
dans les open qui est prometteuse qui
toujours dangereuse tu as les blancs
alors effectivement donc hier tu avais
les noirs et aurait pu peut-être
l'emporter face à ninon qui est une des
trois favorites je crois qu'on peut dire
avec amira même si bien sûr il ya aussi
s'il ya colas et puis natacha
objectivement à une mira est clairement
favorite elle a quand même année le 2450
c'est quand même 100 points de plus par
rapport
encore plus par rapport aux ailes chez
eux après près voilà et c'est les
assaillent d'heure on va bien
without side alors on y va dans cette
partie face à cyrielle or qu'est-ce que
tu as choisi de jouer aux quatre ans we
have eu quatre jours quasiment toujours
recadre donc ça peut varier quand même
des fois je vais pas trop donné
d'indication non effectivement au futur
adversaire alors ou 5 tu t'attendais aux
elle peut jouer aussi ses 5 mais je
m'attendais plutôt à cinq quand même
d'accord qui est plus fréquent dans son
jus ouais je m'attendais ce que je quand
même quelque chose de solide et ses 5 g
plusieurs plusieurs choses donc je
m'attendais plutôt à ça pas trop pas de
surprise voire patronne donc à bf3 câble
et c6 est donc poussé 4me thaliana
laurine italienne
ouais ouais ouais ça j'ai décidé de
jouer
photo une partie assez tranquille je
voulais pas prendre trop de risques
l'italienne s'est parfois tendues ouais
mais bon c'est par rapport à l'espagnol
par exemple
ça peut c'est vrai que c'est une version
que je joue aussi depuis que je suis
petit alors à l'aise quoi plus à l'aise
d'accord tranquille donc on y va sous
ces cinq petit rock cavalière 6 très
théorique
détroit où tranquille des six c3 donc ça
ressemble à des plans espagnol 6-1 parce
que le pouvoir venir en b3 certainement
s est classique qui vous prennent à 6
tranquille nancy 20 des coûts est assez
connu petit roc de 303 parce que s'ils
jouent page 3 il peut y avoir cavaillé
g4
tu peux être un petit peu embêtant mais
qu'à tokyo l'option des 26 je vous fous
b3 calé g4 la joie défend avec tours 2
hélas roi suit avec des idées avec jouer
avec f5 et ça peut être un peu un peu
tendu un peu embêtant que faire à éviter
et puis il ya ça aussi ça empêche le fou
aussi devenir floue et donc ça permet
aussi bouger quête en général c'est peut
être une menace quand j'ai mon fiancé
troyer contrôle de la caisse des quatre
oui donc je vois j'ai jamais trop
dangereux donc c'est plutôt pour
cavaliers g4
c'est plutôt pour que les jets 4
d'accord mais aussi ça te permettra plus
tard d'envisager des 400 risque aussi
fou à 7
ça se joue aussi sa voix on joue à si
c'est parfois pour joe biden mais aussi
pour garder une petite case of où il est
il est bien placé là parce qu'il est on
peut plus attaquer mais il garde toute
son action sur la db9 un cavalier à 5
était possible au lieu de fou à 7
oui et ça avait été mentionné par
cramique dans une
une analyse juste dance porter et
et vont ils disaient que après beckett
et français qui ont français 5 pouces et
ça m'a accueilli à 5 comprend des six
comprend des six est un petit peu mieux
pour les blancs après faut trois ou
quatre auch quoi la cour c'est une
possibilité mais pas jouer ça mais tu
connaissais sa façon s est pas vraiment
puisque tu cites au kram ni donc ça
devrait aller
donc ici fois c'est très bien fait que
trois mamans qui a veillé à 5
oui pourquoi c'est regarder fonctionner
trois oui c'est un fonds important je
réussisse oui c'est normal qu'ils
avaient des deux cas de problème on
change près tout de suite en d3 quoi il
attend rempli de la dame j'ai pris de la
donne mais parce que
moss a exercé une pression sur 17 ouais
attaque bessette effectivement ça posera
une question ici avec le cahier qui sera
attaqué deux positions bon là sur ce
côté là je pense que c'est pas très
important parce que c'est bien défendu
bien sûr mais donc la cave alliage 5
elle profite du fait que la dame est
partie finalement pour jouer ça parce
que évidemment si la dame est encore en
d1 on peut pas vendre à jouer ça parce
que je sais juste comme ça mais alors là
ça on se demander c'est assez surprenant
et j'étais elle a joué assez vite en
plus et je me demandais son idée c'était
peut-être après deux premiers sets dante
c'est long pour regarder çà ou là non
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'elle est
fausse et ceux que j'ai joués d'accord
oui donc ici imaginons deux cavaliers
aux fins d'en reprendre
voilà le premier c'est la mise et 7
ness de gagner l'ademe par fb vite oui
on menace de tours jamais prendre un
échec sur d'un point à 6,6 à fou prend
f2 échec et la torah 8 prendrait la tour
donc la balle adam pardon donc là on est
obligé de revenir la charnière d'un mp3
et là maintenant cavalier quatre
attaques rations des trois attaques des
3 et empêcher qu'il tue pénible ça hein
parce que sam annonce que c'est en fait
et après la c2 gt pas sûr qu'il ya
peut-être des cahiers prend h3 à 80
avaient peur d'une attaque mais bon
c'est avec l'idée derrière d'anjou et f5
rapidement si c'est un clouage sur
lequel faisait méfiait ça fait pas un
peu bloqué cavaliers les cavaliers sont
bloqués la dame a un peu loin le fou
participe pas idiote parce qu'on peut
pas je vous le cavalier les deux parce
qu elle est rentrée en prise si on joue
l'autre cavaliers on peut se prendre
pour un f2 échec
ouais donc c'est difficile avait l'air
très dangereux ça d'accord
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai joué qu'à
elle ya fait un truc qui france était
demandée pourquoi pas prendre mais c'est
magnifiquement ça a l'air dangereux
objectivement cavaliers fin parce que là
en attendant notre coach et ça que
l'énorme envie jouer damev 6 pour faire
kalyev 4 oui mais
après 9,6 là maintenant je peux prendre
en baisse est donc à windsor ont repris
ouais
du coup elle a fait dame 17 mai du coup
la dame et le cas l'année sont pas
coordonnées elles qui améliora ce sens
qui est un petit peu un petit peu oui un
petit peu recours square cours soit elle
accorde d'accord donc je suis pas sûr
que là je vais très précis il fallait
défendre avec tours b 8 pour essayer de
faire près de faire des rêves six mois
ici sera prêt qu'à la fin joue d'abord
trouver 8 pour jouer
voici un élève 6 6 4 6 elisa mes fils et
de protéger la cad et le carton cadeau
en a pas parce que si on joue qu'avec a
tout de suite vous prend et le pion mais
leur jeu c'est ça les patients canadiens
ont fait des quatre étaient complètement
bloquées dans la décade ça tue le foot
ce genre de structure c'est beaucoup
mieux pour les blancs d'accord subtilité
positionnelle donc dans le 17 et
maintenant il faut 3 qui tue le foot
c'est ça ça tunisois 7 qui quand même et
dangereux et c'est l'échangé foyer actif
et puis j'ai envie de jouer des quatre
donc tout rabais uys l'étonnant le
protège parce que ce qu'on essaie de
venir en plaidant là je pense que c'est
une erreur parce que là tout de suite
des problèmes à mon avis après des
quatre lancers zone des là aussi je me
suis demandé on a vu cette position
on s'est demandé pourquoi pas prendre
d'abord un set avant de jouer des cartes
mais en fait si un seuil que je pense je
suis un peu mieux au 6 mai après des
quatre le truc c'est qu'il ya toujours
des trucs tactique et place de t5 et le
cavalier veut pas partir parce que le
fouet en l'air et s'il faut prendre
trois il peut y avoir pour nous français
s'ils s'attaquent l'un des
intermédiaires et donc qu'il ya des
thèmes tels qu'il ya des thèmes
il vaut mieux garder le four et c'est
pour ça que je me suis dit que c'était
union d'accord de le garder oui d'accord
donc d4 avec l'idée qu'on peut jouer de
parfois des cinq et il ya des thèmes sur
fou prendre prendre à bord ans et 6 1
voilà ça marche pas tout de suite
par exemple d'après lequel a joué tout
mais on s'était dit ah oui mais s'ils
ont des idées comme ça des 5 fu prend et
on prend ce qu'on s'est dit simplement
pions prend plus on prend oui la tour
attaque la dame et finalement on va
pouvoir enlever le fou oui mais par
exemple
enfin dans ce cas là je pense que même
ça marche parce qu'après piot france et
6 j'en prends ses 6 ans et 6 m
peut-être d'âme des uns et il ya cahier
province un qui est pas les pros c'est
qu'avec la dame qui attaquent le cavage
cinq classes et c'est possible quoi
d'accord mais bon après si je peux aussi
avoir des comme dans la partie elle a
fait tour et 8
donc on va voir on est tous
effectivement voyage pour ce que voilà
j'ai fait d'amener un d'amd et du coup
je t'aime reviens à la maison et la
maintenance connaissent des 5,5 alors
des singles problème c'est que ça
menaces pions prend qui attaquent la
dame et le fou à cette emprise du fou et
3 par exemple sur des 5-6 les noirs
prennent on prend d'abord le cavalier la
table d'un mythe attaqué et on va gagner
une pièce et en plus là on a en plus une
visée sur le don qu'il ya deux menaces
on sait pas facile
ça que j'ai pas trop vu de coup à part
d'amd vitoux dams est pour elle a joué
27 mai où sa perfection
après cela il va être tour à huit c'est
possible si milla vélo mais aussi la
prise en d 4 ans qui est possible 4 puis
on prend des quatre là déjà j'ai le
centre et surtout reprend ok tu vas voir
probablement cahier g5
il ya des cinq aussi à pas mal de
surtout reprend il ya plein de coups
intéressants oui comme les g5 qui
attaquent la tour j'attaque pas trop
cavalier et ça doit donner la qualité -
trois mariages quand je gagne direct
affiche 5 d'accord c'est pénible donc
dans le bilan n'est pas simple mais là
c'est difficile
strobe lights amos est alors dans le set
ça évite sur des cinq la double attaque
ça cavaliers mais mais ça laisse à me
problème là dessus alors tu afellay est
ensuite forcé en fait donc pas cavaler
prendre 5 quand même ici parce qu'
est-ce que simplement on prend sans
doute d'un prend ensuite pion qui a des
cadets qui le pion 4 qui pendent c'en
est derrière l'accord donc des cinq donc
l' oncle elle obligée de prendre et 3
pas le choix parce que s'il cueille les
bouges évidemment la fois c'est un
problème donc là cavalli prend donc là
c'était contente parce que évident tu
sors ton cavaliers et entame une belle
case magnifiques ici
f5 ça fait plaisir j'ai appris son
cavalier aucune bonne case oui
alors voilà oui effectivement il alors
s'il vient à 5 qu'il ait perdu puisque
b4 et là pas de case en des huit bébés
pas mieux parce que dc comme celle ci
c'est aussi son prix bas il est pas près
de sortir
c'est très difficile pour moi et donc là
car il ya sept et il est pas beau la
prendre du temps pour qu'ils reviennent
à effectivement c'est ce qu'on a ri et
là alors là alors kasparov tu connais le
théorème de kasparov là le cavaliere f5
ça vaut un pion oui c'est vrai que
c'était sympa les orientales yen s'est
en fait l'objectif il est magnifique
parce que rien dans ce cavalier il
attaque la dame y il a un oeil sur g7 en
plus qu'avec on est toujours un peu en
l'air bien maintenant qu'on en plus le
cavalier là en cas de prise bombay la
dame prend
j'avais besoin de faire cailler f5 pour
faire marcher qui a éprouvé 5
ce que si donc la dame et 6 et la dsit
pas 5
c'est un tout petit peu risqué quand
même parce que calais prend 1,5
on se dit surtout reprend il ya quand
même le cavalier qui va être cloué après
mais en fait je contre cloud adam g il
ya un contre tous j'avais donc on va
voir danser ce qui s'est passé tout
reprend et voilà dans prend 1,5 et donc
la cie et noir avaient tenté g6
on peut peut-être même faire cavalier
échec puisque le cavalier pour revenir
ah oui non mais la dame mais je pense
que david holmes j'éclate ça suffit
mais j'ai quatre ici d'objets qu'après
je vais faire qu'allié g3 qui contrôlent
ouvrage vous permet l'essor on a gagné
un pur net avec une magnifique position
tout à fait donc donc là ça marche
enfin d'un projet 5 doudou voilà donc
effectivement tout à profiter de ses
subtiles parce que c'est une très légère
des organisations non il faut être
précis pour en profiter parce que sinon
tu aurais pas pu bien ça permet gagner
un pion quoi avec une exposition autour
des 8
je jouais mg 4 mai sur ça protège quatre
essais ça sort de clouage j'ai réfléchi
un petit moment parce que l'âge 5 était
possible mais bon je vous êtes l'idée
voilà dévier la dame pour prendre leur
quête
je me suis dit que c'était quand même
mon piment après d'un proche cinq tours
prend un catho prend quatre points
catella cavaliers 3 j'étais champion de
descente a pris le plus rage celle
contre aucun cas tu restes avec une
durée de plus values hors jeu parce que
même s'il vient en bessin qui a 4 il est
obligé de revoir de revenir à 7
donc il n'est pas prêt de venir
aujourd'hui c'est vrai le seul à jouer 6
ouais c'est bien ces six parce que ben
oui il ya menace de prendre en d5
c'est quand même pas rien et puis en cas
de prise mais sur le fil revenir le
cavalier ça j'avais pas trop aimé jouer
c4 parce qu'elles ont sur b2 parfois est
peut être l'un des petits problèmes
oui s'éclate affaiblit un peu les
classements là en plus
j'ai pris en six présences et 6 alors pu
activer le cavalier à ce moment là mais
elle laisse le pion des six faiblesse
après qu'elle ait prononcé si je pense
que je fais tourner un award emile a
déjà une idée après dessin vous regardez
alors qu'il sur câbles hypron d612 tour
à leysin et là sur des singes peut faire
f 4l des cinq ans profitant du fait de
la tension il yad'autres tour face à une
ici donc et tu as oui tu fais f4 il me
semble que ça marche parce que surprend
et qui à 30 ans à 4 da comment ici
tourcoing 4 1 tourcoing 4 en francs et
là si elle prend du pion et sodeci tour
des six ça et surtout reprend et surtout
reprend dû prendre des 5e mais aussi est
décédé avec ayem six échecs mais j'étais
pas complètement sûr ah oui parce que la
dame soit dame rose 6 6 mm 6 vitesses et
mas cema des couloirs et peut-être 3f 8
et je sais je sais pas je ne sais être
calculé sa main imaginons qu'ils on
prend quand même pour voir un peu tour
des six et il ya un poil en retrait pour
eux six c'est pas jouable satoru six
sous ça a l'air de tenir on peut y a pas
des mythes il ya pas un peu simplement
on prend en fait sans doute une prise
ici et en cas de prise de la dame alors
si on prend du plomb bon on est
contentes ça fait des pierres doublé
premier set et là j'ai 7 ans l'heure
voilà c'est ça donc on est obligé de
prendre du plomb et puis or la bomba oui
ça c'est pas beaucoup
puis on va revenir et puis ça c'est ça
c'est bon pour les blancs d'accord donc
des des princes hésite donc du coup elle
prend du pion b essayer de regrouper ses
pions pour donner de la force à ces
jolis dessins commission et la
tranquille même car les g3 je reviens
voilà tu manges plus pu jouer quatre
savons menace f4 c'est quand tu as deux
des cinq qui arrive 4 4 ça prend puisque
et le cavalier est ensuite 5 avec des
pions qui sont passés à cette grosse
attaque là le roi va avoir des problèmes
il ya deux pions ici qui ne rêvent que
de ça d'avancer encore un peu plus
d'aller casser la défense du roi donc ça
va être dur donc allégé trois tours des
huit attaques b2c bien manger fait tour
à dire moi c'est bientôt rabbit 3d un
donc ouais je voulais rester actif quand
même pas commencé à faire des coups
passif et tactiquement ça avait l'air de
marcher
après tout quand v 2 alors c'est ce
qu'elle a fait comprendre alors qu'à
l'air quand même actif mais elle
affaiblit quand même sa huitième ici ça
fait peur quand même
ouais mais bon en même temps c'est vrai
que c'est peut-être sa chance
je comprends que tu joues et çà et là tu
4 6 4 alors voilà c'est le moment les
blancs profite du fait que le câble est
hors jeu
la huitième est faible et on veut créer
des menaces tactique vers le centre et
affaiblir en l'euro en noir le câble et
pour revenir soit 1,5 soit en effet 5
avec des menaces
c'est chaud pas facile à défendre donc
tout aussi si toi aussi ça perd tout de
suite en fait alors qu'elle aurait pu
faire ici peut-être vite c'est normal je
crois que 5
c'est ce que je voulais faire tu voulais
faire 5 quand même donc surprise salars
très bon poulet est un poulet oui j'ai
prise seul et qu'il donne 17 et
mensuellement
ah oui peut-être même cave alliage 5 qui
peut menacer qui menace
cinq des six forcé alors sur cavaliers
h5 d'attention il ya donc il ya des
menaces si on peut pas aller n'importe
où si on vit à angers 6 qu'est ce qui se
passe sur dame g6
on peut il ya des menaces par tout ce
qu'on peut prendre le 5 il ya toujours
des mâts du couloir c'est ce qu'on avait
dit qu'on la tour est venu tout de suite
les mains du pouvoir sont là attention
parce qu'en plus on donne à stoke g5 là
ça devient chaud on peut pas prendre
parce qu'il ya mc du couloir et la
menace est toujours g5 donc là par
exemple mettre donc même si on ne défend
la huitième on se prend pour v5 et c'est
foutu ouais d'accord donc c'est très dur
donc même ça c'était ça leur gagnant
déjà pour les blancs il faut dire que
c'est un bon piont de plus avec will
meet a troqué le pion de plus contre
égalité matérielle mais avec un roi
faible en face au problème de mode du
court et puis on travaille dur je veux
tu vis tu pouvais te l'avouer c'est une
pièce de plus en attaque la fesci
recoins toro 6 et la wii donc on n'avait
jamais vu ce coup j'étais content j'ai
vu ça sa 5e cinqs de preuve le mans
gagné aussi
oui là ça vient de gagner en force parce
que là je prends la caisse g63 la laddh
un peu plus venir défendre angers 6 donc
sur une attaque du cavalier être très
dur de protéger le match quoi et puis
surtout à la tour et d'autant que une
fois qu'on a ce matin g7
on peut prendre en d6 avec sept tours
par exemple si la dame blanche comprend
des 6es la dame peut jamais reprendre à
cause du mat
c'est dur là c'est dur
quel jouer à jeu tour est vite atteint 5
toujours en fait y'a qu'à l'âge 5 adam
eux sont peut-être donc d'un prince et
rend à la dame ratio national
donc je fais fort et celle saint laurent
la case ça c'est fort ayez pris il est
pris trois fois mais aucune prise les
bornes alors évidente de la dame on la
perd ça c'est pas moi et de la tour c th
alors si tout reprend ici le 5-5 cavalli
h5 menace cavalli se rendent à michel et
voilà et si les noirs prennent d'abord
ici bon ben on reprendre la tour avec un
matelas au donc le seul coup ici se
semble être non pardon ça semble d'être
de jouer dommages sis d'un mach 6 au
premier cinq variantes et là ça
recommence tout reprendre scène et en
cas de prise c'est l'autre tour qui fait
maths c'est terrible donc 5 très bon
coup
on peut reprendre encore du pion il faut
regarder un celi h5n1 quand même d'un
magistère réussissent trois des six et
tour des six superbes on peut pas
prendre bien sûr à copenhague si on joue
g6 sont coiffés réussissent tout
simplement tranquille et puis il ya
l'autre coup cf6 mais ça m'aurait plu
même si ça l'est pour les 6 quand même
puisque la tour compte donc cinq dames 7
et la km h c'est michelin qui a pâti
superbe magnifique
bah oui alors il ya deux menaces angers7
et aussi la fourchette en effet si ça
dommage cyrielle je pense qu'elle a
peut-être joué un petit peu trop vite à
certains moments
est-ce que c'est assez subtil parfois il
est bon et du coup ça marchait pas très
bien c'est vrai de ne pas prendre trois
aussi jouer calèche 5 puis ensuite des
menaces est donc des coups précis quand
même en ôta pas parce que tu as bien
profiter de lembeye trois dames d un
retour en d1 c'est pas évident de
revenir en débat une fois qu'on a senti
la dame
ouais mais bon c'est vrai que je sentais
qu'il y avait ce cavalier la clé telle
adhésion libre
ouais ouais
bon une belle partie des contente quand
même oui c'est chez contente une partie
c'est quand même un bon point
tactiquement j'ai vu à peu près ce qui
se passait alors on a on a eu aussi on
peut parler un peu l'équipe de france
dont tu fait partie
bien sûr on a eu mathieu hier mathieu
cornette qui est sélectionneur était au
courant comme et donc il nous a dit que
les trois meilleures françaises
vous pouvez pas venir c'est sa méthode
soit thuiller toi moi je suis bon après
elles ont toutes des bonnes raisons
quand même donc qu'ils partagent mon
mari vient d'avoir un enfant poli noël
les médecins oui c'est pas évident pour
aller à lens et rennes ont ces deux
semaines que l'on va pas souvent en
national aussi parce qu'elle était bon
alors mais mon prénom c'est vrai que
marie geveaux palais national mais
pauline non plus n'était pas l'ami non
mais c'est vrai que quand on travaille à
plein temps ouais c'est vrai choix voilà
pour n'a pas forcément envie de prendre
dix jours de vacances pour ouais c'est
bonjour un tournoi je comprends qu'ils
aient quand même elle qui est quand même
aussi fatiguant que de tout mais voilà
de fer entre autres face après un an de
travail est en faillite comme une belle
équipe puisque du coup on
rien à perdre il ya andré hahn a voté ce
qui'il fait son entrée donc c'est bien
de jeunes je pense qu'ils soient des
cuivres qui découvrait qu'il doit france
puis on bat voilà moi ça va être
difficile de toute façon il est quand
même des très grosses équipes on y va
sans pression
ben voilà c'est ça avait tout à gagner
et puis est d'essayer de faire un
résultat
c'est parfois mieux ne pas partir favori
d'ailleurs parce que c'est plus dur
d'être de tenir une position de favori
que des outsiders
et puis bon déjà c'est un moyen aussi de
progresser et de cette façon c'est
comment s internationaux d'accord alors
bien sûr on sera très attentif à ta
partie prochaine face à al mira puisque
c'est notre favorite a déjà joué nino ce
sera la dernière
donc ses adhérents en espérant que à ce
moment là bien sûr vous soyez encore
disons tout à coup deux pour que ça se
joue ce qui est pas sûr parce que on ira
à l'air de primes bien
elle était alors on connaît pas le
résultat encore de sa partie face à
ninon mais elle était comme il n'y a pas
d'énergie complètement gagnant sa valeur
à ces gagnants et puis sylvia colas
aussi qui fait un bon début de tournoi
elle avait une très bonne position il a
gagné manière très convaincante
je sais avec deux fois les pièces noires
donc ça sera femmes c'est peut-être son
année aussi il faut faire attention à la
déjà gagné le titre il a déjà signé une
croix colonnes quitteront le centre
pasquart également cette fois c'est déjà
pas mal
voilà c'était le studio canal tv
deuxième journée à agen en 2016 avec une
super championne en france sophie millet
bien sûr que tout le monde apprécie
merci beaucoup sophie nous à les
rejoindre sur studio je vous donne
rendez vous pour la rendre de numéro 3
de ce national la prochaine fois au
revoir à bientôt